que usa dinero de papel cuando el resto del mundo mude a digital?
Otro ejemplo de mi ciudad natal, Filadelfia:
recientemente fui allí a la biblioteca pública,
y están teniendo una crisis existencial.
La financiación pública está bajando,
deben reducir su presencia para seguir abiertos y relevantes,
y una forma de hacer esto
es digitalizar varios libros y moverlos a la nube.
Es magnífico para los chicos, ¿verdad?
Puede retirar libros desde casa,
puede investigar yendo y viniendo del colegio,
pero estas son dos grandes suposiciones,
primero, que tiene acceso en casa,
segundo, que tiene acceso en el móvil,
y en Filadelfia, muchos chicos no los tienen.
Así que, ¿cómo será su experiencia educativa
en una biblioteca basada completamente basada en la nube
que antes era una parte básica de su educación?
¿Cómo se mantendrán competitivos?
Un ejemplo final desde África Este:
hay un gran movimiento para digitalizar derechos de propiedad de tierra,
por varias razones.
Comunidades migratorias, viejas generaciones que mueren,
y básicamente un mal manejo de registros
ha llevado a conflictos sobre propiedad.
Así que hay un gran movimiento para poner esta información en línea,
y rastrear la propiedad de estos lotes de tierra,
llevarlos a la nube y entregarlos a las comunidades.
Pero realmente, la consecuencia accidental de esto
ha sido que inversores de riesgo, y constructores de finca raíz,
se han precipitado a comprar estos lotes de tierra
por encima de estas comunidades,
porque tienen acceso a las tecnologías
y la conectividad que las hace posibles.
Este es el denominador común que conecta estos ejemplos,
las consecuencias accidentales de los aparatos y las tecnologías que creamos.
Como ingenieros, como tecnólogos,
a veces preferimos eficiencia a eficacia.
Pesamos más en hacer cosas que en los resultados de lo que hacemos.
Esto debe cambiar.
Tenemos la responsabilidad de pensar en los resultados de las tecnologías,
especialmente cuando cada vez controlan más el mundo en que vivimos.
A finales de los 90
había una gran presión por ética en el mundo financiero y bancario,
Pienso que en el 2014 se ha retrasado un movimiento similar
en el área de tecnología.
Así que los animo a pensar en la siguiente gran cosa,
como emprendedores, gerentes, ingenieros y creadores,
a pensar acerca de las consecuencias accidentales
de las cosas que estamos creando,
porque la verdadera innovación es encontrar formas de incluir a todos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)